I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hey everybody! Hello!
We are very excited about our new podcast. We are. It starts on October 16th. But we wanted to give you a little sneak peek. Each week we'll break down a new episode of The Office. We're starting at the beginning and going in order. So you can watch along with us. In each episode we will give you what I like to call Fast Facts.
You do like to call them that. She made it up, folks. She's very proud. I did and I am. So you'll get three Fast Facts and then after the Fast Facts we will go through the episode. And we're going to tell you behind-the-scenes stories. Oh, Jenna, I have one. Okay.
Okay, okay. So do you remember Booth's Cruise? Of course. All right. So here's the deal about Booth's Cruise. You guys, these were night shoots. We never did night shoots. That's true.
We would show up for Booth's Cruise. We had to go to a boat in Long Beach. We had to get there at like 4 p.m. and we filmed till like 5 in the morning. Well one of the fun things was that we all got hotel room. I know! So it was like a big slumber party. Jenna, I have been wanting to ask you this question. I don't know why I've never asked you this question, but did you have to do the puking
scene? No. What? Yeah. I didn't have to do it. Son of a- I know. I know.
A lot of you guys did though, right? Yes. Here's the thing. Greg Daniels thought it'd be really funny if a bunch of people in the episode got seasick. Yes. Yeah. Well a lot of people in real life got seasick. Oh, in real life people were like turning green.
Yacking off the side of that boat. I know. It had this like subtle like roll back and forth and people got like, they got like really sick and everyone had those bracelets with the little- Which don't really work. They don't work, you guys. Sorry to ever mix them, but we didn't have success with them. Anyway, so here we are shooting all night long and Greg comes up to me.
It's like one in the morning. Greg Daniels, our showrunner, creator, and he's like, hey, Angela, will you do some of the puking stuff? Kate Flannery's going to do it. I was like, what? He was just grabbing random people to get puking shots. Yeah. In between scenes, he would take the B camera operator and we would go out on the back of
the boat and you had two choices. You could take a big swig of cold Minestrone soup or cold cream of mushroom. What did you pick? Oh, God. It was so disgusting. I took a big swig. Do you have any guesses? I'm guessing you picked Minestrone, that's what I would have picked.
Yes. That's what I picked. I picked Minestrone. And they said, okay, take a huge, you know, swallow and hold it in your mouth until we say action and on action, spew it out. And I want you to know like the 10 seconds it took them to like get the camera ready, holding that cold soup in my mouth. I literally started to physically gag like, and then I, and then on action they were like
spew. And then none of it ended up in the episode. Oh my gosh. And we did like three takes of fake puking off the side of the boat. That's gross. And that is a sneak peek of Office Ladies. You're welcome, everybody. You're welcome.
I learned something I didn't know. Well, good. You guys, come hang out with us while we watch the office and, you know, be best friends. Office Ladies premieres October 16th. Subscribe now in Apple Podcasts, Stitcher, or wherever you listen. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.